when I was young I used to want to
design a utopian world as I got more
mature I realized the world that I would
love to live in would be a world treated
by seven billion pairs of hands each
making their own part of the world a
better place my name is Jay silver and
the co-creator of making me and as
actually Intel's first make a research
scientist we don't try to teach people's
minds we try to ignite people's hearts
Mickey Mickey is a little circuit and it
lets you hook up everyday objects and
repurpose their meaning you can grab
bananas and hook them up to your laptop
and connect them together with alligator
clips and boom you've got a banana peel
one place makey makey came out of is
physical contact with everyday objects
the whole purpose of that is really so
that you can look around you and you can
think to yourself the world is really
just a construction kit and meaning is
something that I can designate I want to
give everybody a little bit of
experience with giving new purpose to
the world they live in
I started at MIT for electrical
engineering then I switched to media
arts and sciences and I worked in that
group called the lifelong kindergarten I
got to use all my engineering experience
to bring user interfaces to life that
real people would use everyday and then
I took what I learned there in the
lifelong kindergarten over to Intel
where I was a maker research scientist
life is better when you can make your
own solutions and so what you want to
receive on the other end of a technology
is something that you can put to use in
your own weight and make something
unique that fits your lifestyle can you
show me how it works
and so what we want to receive is
creative tools and powerful tools and
that's something Intel's working on one
thing that's cool about the until 2 + 1
PC is that you really can compact it and
get some really powerful embedded
prototyping going with makey makey it's
pretty easy to get all that power that's
in the 2 + 1 PC and make it react to the
everyday environment so they're a good
combo one of the things that I really
like about Intel is that it was founded
by makers and I think the powerhouses of
the future of the economy are going to
be places where there's a lot of people
who know how to make
and then tell us one of those places we
believe that everybody can invent and
make things and change the world that's
why we invented making me when we make
our world we make a better world